this is ver money a martial Eagle the
largest African Eagle they have enough
power in one foot to break a human arm
as powerful as they are their strength
in numbers continues to decrease in the
wild martial eagles weigh in at around
14 pounds with a wingspan up to eight
and a half feet
bomani is native to sub-saharan Africa
preferring urban woods wooded savanna
and thorn bush habitats he is an apex
predator sitting at the top of the avian
food chain unfortunately they are being
persecuted by humans mistakenly believed
to be a predatory threat to livestock in
reality domestic animals make up a very
small percentage of their diet add to
that a shrinking habitat which reduces
prey the martial eagle population is
dwindling fast this is the martial eagle
this is Kamaria a milky eagle al the
largest African al it is found
throughout sub-saharan Africa the eagle
in their name refers to their large size
females are much larger than males
sometimes over third bigger they feed on
a large variety of animals everything
from mammals fish rodents and even large
birds they hunt from a perch using their
sharp vision to spot prey before flying
in and seizing them with their powerful
talons while it is a dominant bird its
population has seen a decline due to a
combination of loss of suitable habitat
hunting disease and droughts the slow
reproductive rate has made it difficult
for the population to recover quickly
this is the milky evil al
[Music]
this is Olivia an East African crowned
crane she is stunning
[Music]
she stands about four feet tall with a
wingspan of six and a half feet her legs
are long and slender perfect for wading
through grassy areas mostly gray the
wings are predominantly white with a
range of colors while her head is full
of golden feathers East African crowned
cranes are well known for their
elaborate dancing these cranes are
omnivores eating everything from plants
to insects snakes small fish and more
native to eastern sub-saharan Africa and
down to South Africa they prefer living
in grassland areas near the water the
crowned crane is the national bird of
Uganda featured on its flag but even
with such iconic status we're losing
them in less than ten years that
population has decreased by over 50%
habitat loss an illegal removal of eggs
and birds from the wild are its biggest
threats this is the East African crowned
crane
[Music]
this is Lily an African penguin she's a
jackass no really
African penguins are commonly known as
jackass penguins their nickname comes
from the donkey like sounds they make
but then our donkey these little guys
grow up to only a little over two feet
and weigh up to eight pounds they are
only found on the south western coast of
Africa where they are a popular site for
tourists however experts say that if
their population decline isn't stopped
they'll be extinct in 15 years you see
African penguins are pursuit divers and
feed mostly on fish and squid but
because of competition from commercial
fishing they have to go further and
further to find enough to eat
that combined with encroaching human
development poaching for eggs and oil
spills are all taking a toll on its
population this is the African penguin
[Music]
this is a Molly she's an addicts she's
also a new mom
her calf Adaline is just three weeks old
and she's very important because the
Attucks is a critically endangered
species the Attucks
is a native of the sahara desert and
once roamed over vast areas of north
africa they're also known as the screw
horn antelope it's easy to see why they
are extremely well adapted to life in
the desert their white coats reflect the
scorching Sun and they splayed hoofs are
perfectly tailored for traversing desert
sands the Attucks can also survive
extremely long periods without water but
these adaptations are no help against
humans the Attucks has been hunted
nearly into oblivion estimates put their
population at less than 200 individuals
in just a few pockets of the Sahara
luckily reintroduction efforts and
captive breeding programs like the one
that produced little Adeline are helping
the survival of this species that has
all but disappeared from the face of the
earth
this is the Attucks
[Music]
this is Juba an Eastern black Reiner
coming in at around two thousand six
hundred and ninety pounds big is an
understatement but with less than seven
hundred and forty left in the wild the
Easton Black Reiner is one of the rarest
trainers in the world Juba is 20 years
old and stands close to 12 feet long
they are solitary animals with an
aggressive disposition to discourage
predators they may seem tranquil but
they will charge first and investigate
later black rhinos are browsers and eat
leafy plants branches shoots and
whatever else they can find in the
Highland and Savannah habitats his large
ears convert eight to pick up sounds
from many directions today Eastern black
rhinos are only left in Kenya and
Tanzania the population has declined by
90 percent over the last three
generations
the biggest threat for these guys are
humans as poaching has absolutely
devastated their population
this is the Easton black rider
[Music]
this is coda a three-year-old African
cheetah critically endangered less than
8,000 remain in the wild the African
cheetah is built for speed it's the
world's fastest land animal
clocking 0 to 60 miles per hour in a
mere 3.4 seconds long and lean with a
flexible spine they use their tail as a
rudder steering when running after prey
they stalk their prey
under the bright Sun of the African
savannah the tear marks that run across
their face help reflect the glare of the
Sun much like football players apply
paint beneath their eyes before a game
they once roamed across all of Africa
but today are found in less than a
quarter of their historic range habitat
loss poaching and loss of prey are all
threats to this beautiful cat this is
the African cheetah
this is awadhi an African lion these
stunning big cats are Africa's apex
predator they once roamed most of Africa
and parts of Europe and Asia but today
they are only found in parts of
sub-saharan Africa Zawadi is a male lion
indicated by his Lodge mane lions are
considered the only social member of the
cat family and live in large groups
called prides females do most of the
hunting and work in teams ambushing
their prey their importance to the
ecosystem is paramount playing a key
role in the food chain
controlling herbivore populations but
while they are the alpha predators they
face threats of their own a combination
of trophy hunting and habitat loss has
cut their population in half over the
past two decades
this is the African lion
[Music]
this is an African elephant the largest
land mammal in the world so large that
it dwarfed our backdrop while
conservation efforts have made
significant gains the threat of poaching
still looms over the future of this
giant species distributed through the
deserts and jungles of sub-saharan
Africa their large ears radiate heat to
keep cool in the African Sun they eat a
lot
everything from roots fruits grasses and
bark and up to 600 pounds of it a day
the tusks are firm teeth used for
digging roots stripping bark from trees
and for fighting and defending
themselves
unfortunately these ivory tusks can
fetch quite a price on the black market
poaching for the illegal ivory trade
continues to be a devastating problem
this is the African elephant
[Music]
you